bemerkungen machen weil in den kommenden
tagen sich auf der internationalen bühne
vieles ereignet wird was auch für uns in
deutschland außerordentlich wichtig sein
wird
nächste woche wird zum beispiel ganz im
zeichen der ersten auslandsreise von
präsident beiden stehen und die tatsache
dass eben diese erste auslandsreise nach
europa führt zunächst zum g 7 gipfel
nach cornwall zur nato und dann zur
europäischen union nach brüssel ist wie
wir finden ein gutes und starkes zeichen
für die transatlantische erneuerungen
und es gehört auch zur ehrlichkeit dazu
dass man sagen muss dass wir darauf
lange gewartet haben dann in den letzten
jahren unter der vorgänger
administration gab es durch
entwicklungen die uns befürchten ließen
dass die internationale ordnung wirklich
nachhaltigen schaden erleiden wird und
deshalb sind wir in dieser zeit oft in
die bresche gesprungen
wir haben um einige beispiele zu
erwähnen unser politisches gewicht in
die waagschale geworfen etwa beim erhalt
des nuklear abkommens mit dem iran wo
wir seit anfang april in wien mit den
anderen vertragsstaaten aber auch
mittelbar mit den vereinigten staaten
verhandeln aber das gilt genauso für
themen der klima und auch der
handelspolitik wir haben in dieser zeit
große finanzielle lücken geschlossen bei
der humanitären hilfe bei der
impfstoffversorgung und bei der
finanzierung internationaler
organisationen und ich bin dem bundestag
außerordentlich dankbar dafür dass er
jedes jahr in den haushaltsverhandlungen
dafür uns auch ausreichend mittel zur
verfügung gestellt hat wir haben ebenso
in dieser schwierigen zeit versucht neue
formen
der flexiblen internationalen
zusammenarbeit auf den weg zu bringen
ich will nur die allianz für den
multilateralismus nennen der
mittlerweile über 70 staaten weltweit
aus allen kontinenten angehören
wo wir über viele wichtige themen etwa
die das thema autonome waffensysteme des
was kann man tun gegen diese
informationskampagne bis hin zum thema
schutz der menschenrechte im digitalen
zeitalter uns nicht mehr ausgetauscht
haben sondern gemeinsame richtlinien
erarbeitet haben die von den mitgliedern
dieser allianz in den internationalen
organisationen dann auch mitgetragen
werden wir können darauf aufbauen denn
jetzt in den kommenden tagen finden
diese wichtigen veranstaltungen statt
beim g7-gipfel wird die bewältigung der
pandemie folgen im mittelpunkt stehen
mit dem klaren bekenntnis zur globalen
impfstoffversorgung und es wird
natürlich auch um das thema klimaschutz
geht vor allen dingen im zusammenhang
mit der kopf 26
in glasgow letztlich muss aber auch und
das ist uns ganz besonders wichtig
dieses treffen auch ein signal der
unterstützung senden an und so wehrte
partner an unsere demokratischen partner
weltweit denn in den letzten jahren hat
es daran wie wir finden doch arg
gemangelt beim nato gipfel am 14 juni
wird es darum gehen das bündnis zukunft
festzumachen und anzupassen an ein
verändertes sicherheitsumfeld dafür
steht der nato 2030 prozess und wir
können dabei aufbauen auf einen
reflexionsprozess den wir angeregt haben
innerhalb der nato und der ganz
maßgeblich von thomas de maizière ein
mitglied dieses hauses geleitet wurde
zusammen mit einem amerikanischen
kollegen und viele viele vorschläge
gemacht hat die uns in der nato noch
lange beschäftigen werden beim eu usa
gipfel wird nicht zuletzt über die
einrichtung eines gemeinsamen handelns
und techno technologie rates verhandelt
werden und hoffentlich auch eine lösung
gefunden werden auch das ist ein thema
für das wir uns in der vergangenheit
immer stark gemacht haben im kern wird
es auch bei diesen themen insbesondere
bei den handels themen darum gehen
wegzukommen von gegenseitigen zöll und
sanktionen und hin zu einem gemeinsamen
antworten auf die drängende frage wie
kann man freien handel besser verbinden
mit umwelt- und sozialstandards und das
ist ja die diskussion die auch
gesellschaftlich immer wieder geführt
wird wenn wir über freihandelsabkommen
diskutieren
und letztlich haben die
g7-finanzminister beim thema globale
mindeststeuer letzte woche ja bereits
einen durchbruch geschafft auf den wir
schon lange gewartet haben und
schließlich begrüßen wir auch die
bereitschaft von präsident biden zu
einem treffen mit präsident putin am 16
juni in genf
wir haben gegenüber russland in den
letzten jahren immer einen klaren kurs
vertreten der auf größere resilienz aber
zugleich eben auch so wie das auch hier
in der debatte eben immer wieder gesagt
wurde dankenswerterweise die fortsetzung
des offenen dialoges selbst in
schwierigsten part wasser gesetzt und
das wird auch in zukunft so sein und ich
glaube dass das treffen auf dieser ebene
dazu auch beitragen kann dass es
anscheinend zwischen den usa russland
möglichkeiten gibt sich auch schnell zu
verständigen hat man zum beispiel daran
gesehen dass wenige tage nachdem die
beiden im amt gewesen ist der new start
verlängert wurde
auf der basis einer verständigung die
sehr schnell gefasst wurde und wir
hoffen darauf dass es in der folge von
genf zu weiteren substanziellen
absprachen kommt und wir erwarten dabei
auch eng eingebunden zu sein zusammen
mit anderen partnern
denn letztlich geht es bei der nuklearen
rüstungskontrolle auch um die sicherheit
europas und meine damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen dass die
amerikanische regierung bei all diesen
themen das ist die erfahrung aus den
letzten monaten ganz besonders auch auf
die zusammenarbeit mit deutschland setzt
das eröffnet uns neue
gestaltungsmöglichkeiten und wir werden
sie auch nutzen etwa indem wir uns in
strategischen fragen wie dem umgang mit
china noch enger abstimmen werden
dass wir dabei möglicherweise nicht
immer eins zu eins auf einer linie
liegen dass wird niemanden überraschen
und die gute und enge zusammenarbeit ich
komme zum schluss herr präsident zeigt
sich nicht zuletzt auch in dem
amerikanischen beschluss sanktions
entscheidungen in sachen nord stream
zwei auszusetzen und zwar ganz
ausdrücklich so hat es der präsident
selbst gesagt um das verhältnis mit
deutschland als freund und verbündeten
nicht weiter zugelassen herzlichen dank
die erste frage stellt der kollege armin
paul humble afd
danke sehr präsident herr bundesminister
sind jedoch verhältnismäßig jung in
diesem amt ich habe die außenpolitik
letzten 30 jahre war das lebens verfolgt
und bedienen vielleicht eine kleine
übersetzungshilfe geben wenn ich die
äußerung des us außenministers höre dass
nach ihren gesprächen in den usa zu
nordring zwei deutschland nun am
verhandlungstisch angekommen sei auf
deutsch übersetzt ist das an sich an
geringschätzung so ungefähr auf
diplomatischen wo das niedrigste level
was sie erreichen können
meine frage ist wie interpretieren sie
denn die äußerung von einem pinken sie
sind jetzt am verhandlungstisch bei
einem deutsch russischen projekt dank
der würde des amerikanischen ist
angekommen
ich bin ich habe gerade vor kurzem noch
mal mit tony blinken telefoniert auch
über die system und wir sind beide sehr
froh darüber dass wir über dieses thema
sprechen das übrigens genau das was die
deutsche bundesregierung auch in den
letzten jahren immer wieder gesagt hat
dass weniger bank zu sanktionen verhängt
werden soll sondern dass man zusammen
darüber sprechen sollte wie die
schwierigen fragen bei 19 2 was bedeutet
das für die ukraine was bedeutet das für
länder in mittel und osteuropa sprechen
können das tun wir jetzt das ist ganz
hervorragend ich bin sehr froh dass das
gelungen ist
sie haben eine frage nicht gewarnt
bei ihnen angekommen ist wie
interpretieren sie eine solche äußerung
am verhandlungstisch angekommen aber
herr blick hat ihnen ja schon den weg so
ein bisschen gewiesen wie man das
problem vom eis kriegen könnte wenn ich
das richtig interpretiere die ausfall
möglichen ausfälle für die ukraine durch
weniger gas transfers durch ihre
pipeline erzeugt ein milliardendefizit
in kiew und wenn ich ja im lincoln
richtig interpretiere hat ja auch schon
uns aus gesehen dafür dass wir mögliche
ausfälle der ukraine dann finanziell
entschädigen soll wahrscheinlich
verfügen sie über intensive beziehungen
zu dem amerikanischen außenminister mehr
hat er das in der form noch nicht
mitgeteilt aber wenn es eben geteilt hat
bin ich dankbar für den hinweis ich
werde das in der bundesregierung auch
weiter dafür breiten der kollegin eine
klamme geplant ist weiterhin die
nachfrage dazu ja in dem zusammenhang
herr minister der außenpolitische
berater der bundeskanzlerin der
wirtschaftspolitische berater der
bundeskanzlerin und ihre
staatssekretären waren kürzlich in
washington haben mit sullivan wörns den
und anderen gesprochen exakt zu diesem
thema würden sie den bundestag darüber
informieren was dort besprochen worden
ist was die amerikaner uns vorgeschlagen
haben denn in der tat ist es ja so dass
jetzt wo die erste röhre von notz den
zwei fertig ist
wladimir putin gesagt petersburg bereits
die geopolitische dimension des projekts
deutlich gemacht hat er hat gesagt wenn
die ukraine weiter gas transit will muss
sie sich so verhalten wie wir uns das in
moskau wünschen das ist genau das was
die amerikaner ja immer uns vorgehalten
haben also was ist dort besprochen
worden mit holländer zu den roller und
hacker abgeordnete ist die themen
besprochen worden die ich eben bereits
erwähnt habe es wird im übrigen diese
woche in diesem kreis eine erneute
videokonferenz- gebe und wir wollen sehr
engmaschig die themen weiter besprechen
wir sind noch nicht dort das ich
lösungen verkünden könnte
aber es geht tatsächlich um die
auswirkung auf die ukraine durch nord
stream zwei wie sie wissen haben wir
einen gas transit vertrag zwischen der
ukraine und russland versucht
mitzuverhandeln denen gibt es der ist
aber zeitlich befristet es stellt sich
die frage ob er nicht auch entfristet
werden kann
ukraine mehr planungssicherheit zu geben
es geht insbesondere darum wie sie
wissen sind wir seit einiger zeit sehr
bemüht in der so genannten drei mehrere
initiative fuß zu fassen in denen auch
die vereinigten staaten zusammen mit
mittel- und osteuropäischen ländern über
viele konnektivitäts aber auch
energiefragen sprechen auch dort könnten
wir uns vorstellen und stärker
einzubringen
das auf der basis unterschiedlicher
unterschiedlicher projekte die jetzt
auch noch nicht spruchreif sind aber ich
bin gerne bereit sobald sich die dinge
konkretisieren in diese gespräche haben
begonnen mit dem ersten termin in
washington sie werden jetzt auf video
konferenz ebene fortgesetzt und wir
haben uns zum ziel gesetzt bis zum
august das ist der zeitraum bis in den
usa der nächste berichtigungen gelegt
werden muss vor dem senat dass wir bis
dorthin sehr konkrete ergebnisse erzielt
haben über die sobald sie vorliegen wird
natürlich auch umgehend im bundestag
informieren werden der kollege sarrazin
bündnis solle die grünen oder eine
weitere nachfrage herr außenminister sie
haben jetzt die chance verpasst die
ihnen herr längst aufgegeben hat sich
nochmal eindeutig und klar mit einer
bewertung zu putins äußerung hier zu
verhalten
die geopolitische dimension dieser
äußerung anzusprechen und vielleicht
auch klar zu machen dass die
bundesregierung auch nach 20 24
relevante gas-transit mengen durch die
ukraine befürwortet und von der
russischen seite verlangt und ich wollte
einfach die chance geben noch mit ein
bisschen mehr redezeit das jetzt hier
nachzuholen herr sarrazin das ist wie
immer sehr freundlich von eben
herzlichen dank dafür ich finde aber es
ergibt sich auch aus der antwort die ich
gerade gegeben habe nämlich wir haben
uns um darum bemüht dass es überhaupt
ein gas transit vertrag zwischen
russland und der ukraine gibt die
bundeskanzlerin hat sehr deutlich
gemacht gegenüber dem russischen
präsidenten dass das für sie eine
voraussetzung dafür ist dass das neue
team zwei projekt wie geplant
fortgesetzt werden kann dh dem ist
dann auch genüge getan worden wir würden
uns auch vorstellen können darüber
gespräch zu führen dass dieser transit
vertrag über die laufzeit der bisher hat
weiter verlängert wird weil wir wollen
dass langfristig das auch durch die
ukraine transferiert wird weil das für
wird aus wirtschaftlichen gründen für
die ukraine außerordentlich bedeutsam
ist ich würde mal sagen jeder wenn sie
die äußerungen von präsident putin
angesprochen haben
das wohlfeiles verhalten der ukraine
voraussetzung dafür ist dass dieser
vertrag auch eingehalten wird wir geben
grundsätzlich mal davon aus pacta sunt
servanda aber wer sich auf diese ebene
begibt der muss natürlich auch damit
rechnen dass er die voraussetzungen
dafür schafft dass in anderen pipelines
man ähnlich beginnt darüber nachzudenken
ob aufgrund von politischen
entscheidungen oder politischen
fehlverhalten man möglicherweise auch
ein solches projekt oder ein bereits in
betrieb genommenes projekt noch einmal
in seinem kompletten betrieb unter die
lupe nehmen müsste ich glaube das ist
nicht im interesse der russischen
föderation und deshalb gehe ich davon
aus dass wir die voraussetzung schaffen
können langfristig gas auch durch die
ukraine zu leiten die nächste frage
stellt der kollege alexander graf
lambsdorff fdp
vielen dank herr präsident wir freuen
uns der minister das haben sie eben
schon gesagt auf den besuch des
amerikanischen präsidenten und europas
an das einer ganzen reihe von
gipfeltreffen eines der wichtigsten ist
ganz sicher das treffen der g7 bei
diesem anlass wollen die vereinigten
staaten das war bereits nachzulesen das
nationale bild berg better project
globalisieren bild bag better world
das ist aus sicht der fraktion der
freien demokraten eine eine gute idee
denn worum geht es es geht darum dem
schädlichen einfluss chinas in
zahlreichen weltregionen mit seiner band
in roth initiative etwas
entgegenzusetzen
aus ihrem haus ist waren handelsblatt
nachzulesen gibt es dazu auch ideen und
anregungen insbesondere der europäischen
investitionsbank eine zentrale rolle bei
der entwicklungsfinanzierung einzuräumen
dass wir europäische einen eigenen
beitrag leisten also eine europäische
investitions und klima bank global
aufstellen
meine frage an sie ist erstens was
erwarten sie ganz konkret was die
umsetzung betrifft wie realistisch sehen
sie dass zweitens was erwarten sie von
der europäischen kommission und drittens
hat die bundesregierung sich im board of
governance der europäischen
investitionsbank bereits dazu geäußert
und dort eine initiative unternommen zu
letzterem das ist noch nicht der fall
wäre das zurzeit noch innerhalb der
bundesregierung abstimmen wir sprechen
auch mit unseren europäischen partnern
darüber weil wir die initiative von
präsident biden grundsätzlich
unterstützen
dies ist auch bereits ein thema gewesen
auf dem g7 außenministertreffen in
london vor einigen wochen
und dabei haben wir uns darauf
verständigt dass es nach dem es auch
dort eine grundsätzliche übereinstimmung
gegeben hat dass wir jetzt daran gehen
diese dinge zu konkretisieren
wir brauchen auch konkrete vorschläge
diese sollen auf dem g7-gipfel dann
gesprochen diskutiert und womöglich und
hoffentlich auch beschieden werden kann
ganz grundsätzlich sind wir uns darüber
einig dass wir uns nicht nur darüber
aufregen müssen was china tut und wie
china versucht mit wirtschaftlichen und
finanziellen mitteln auch geopolitisch
seinen einfluss zu mehreren sondern wir
müssen alternativen schaffen
das geht etwa für afrika für
südeuropa das gilt für lateinamerika und
das gilt auch für den in oak pacific und
das ist die arbeit die wir uns
vorgenommen haben und das sind einige
instrumente oder ein instrument das sie
genannt haben bei dem wir der auffassung
sind dass es dabei helfen können
nachfrage wenn ich da bin ich gern noch
mal ganz konkret es war zu lesen dass
sehr viel kritik an der antwort der
europäischen kommission auf ihren brief
den sie gemeinsam mit zwei
kabinettskollegen geschrieben haben gab
worin besteht konkret die kritik an der
kommission zweite frage ich stelle fest
dass wir uns einig sind dass so ein
europäischer beitrag sinnvoll ist können
sie mir erklären warum die regierung
tragenden fraktionen einen solchen
antrag seiner fraktion vor kurzem erst
in diesem haus abgelehnt haben
das kann ich mir nicht erklären aber das
wird die oder während die
regierungsfraktionen sicherlich auch tun
können
die kommission will sich hinsichtlich
das thema ist dass sie angesprochen
haben mit anderen mitgliedstaaten weiter
abstimmen das ist bisher noch nicht dem
falle oder so umfassend möglich gewesen
ganz grundsätzlich haben wir aber die
hoffnung dass wir in den gesprächen mit
der kommission es schaffen dafür auch
ein positives umfeld zu finden und zu
schaffen das allerdings im moment noch
nicht in dem umfang der fall ist wie wir
uns das gewünscht hätten
das ist richtig dazu hat der kollege
hubble hfd eine nachfrage und dann der
kollege trittin
ja danke herr präsident damit es dann
da ich war der rede in salzburg anwesend
war halb von einer geopolitischen
dimension hat er nicht gesprochen
konkret sogar auf die wirtschaftliche
perspektive der nordstream zwar leitung
in die werkstatt ist für deutschland wie
für russland ein projekt was unter rein
wirtschaftlichen nutzen zu sehen ist
erstens das gas ist billiger und
zweitens für die klima freunde es ist
auch noch in einer art und weise
gefördert wie das im gegensatz zum
fracking usa der von umwelt schonender
stattfindet aber noch mal konkret
nachgefragt hat sich jetzt noch mal die
ukraine bewertet haben und der präsident
ja auch ausführte werden die ukraine
ihre verträge einhält 40 milliarden
kubikmeter gas sollen transportiert
werden wenn sie die verträge einhalten
wie das weiter noch mal konkret wenn aus
irgendwelchen gründen die vielleicht die
ukraine zu verantworten hat das nicht
der fall ist wird sich die
bundesregierung dagegen wehren dass sie
eventuelle ausbaukosten der ukraine
begleicht das ist bisher von niemandem
an mich herangetragen worden ich gehe
auch nicht davon aus dass das der fall
ist
wir gehen davon aus dass die ukraine
selber ein großes interesse daran hat
die voraussetzungen zu schaffen also
ihren teil des vertrags einzuhalten weil
sie milliarden beträge dafür bekommt pro
jahr
und deshalb kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass die ukraine ein problem
ist wenn es darum geht dass beide seiten
über vertragserfüllung gerecht werden
der kollege jürgen trittin bündnis 90
die grünen hatte eine weitere nachfrage
bundesminister im anschluss an die frage
von den kollegen lambsdorff bild weg
wetter ist ein komplett kreditfinanziert
das programm wenn das jetzt globalisiert
werden soll und verstetigt werden
glauben sie dass mit dieser überlegung
innerhalb der europäischen union die
vorstellung dass die anleihe die man für
die green oder für den recovery fund
aufgelegt hat eine ausnahme ist oder
sehen sie nicht vielmehr die
notwendigkeit dass europa wie die usa
wenn es in diesem wettbewerb treten
wollen mit china
diese programme auch künftig über
anleihen spricht kreditfinanziert machen
muss und dass dafür die potenziale der
europäischen investitionsbank schlicht
und ergreifend nicht ausreichen sie
wissen dass es dazu beim wiederaufbau
programm auch eine intensive diskussion
gegeben hat innerhalb der europäischen
union auch innerhalb der bundesregierung
wir sind der auffassung gewesen dass
diese möglichkeiten genutzt werden
sollten das hat deutschland und
frankreich in einem gemeinsamen papier
auch vorgeschlagen dass die grundlage
der verständigung oder des kompromisses
sind daher innerhalb der europäischen
union gewesen ist inwieweit man darauf
aufsetzen kann aus der ausnahme eine
weitere ausnahme zu genehmigen ich
glaube nicht dass es darum geht den
regelfall zu machen wird darüber zu
sprechen darüber wird zu sprechen sein
er wird innerhalb der eu zu sprechen
sein auch mit den anderen
mitgliedstaaten ob diese einigung zu
erzielen ist in dem sinne wie sie es
oder wie ich es ihren worten entnommen
haben für sinnvoll hielten glaube ich
wird keine einfache diskussion innerhalb
der europäischen union sein
wir haben dies auch abschließend
innerhalb der bundesregierung noch zu
besprechen
ich glaube aber dass man sich dieser
diskussion zumindest öffnen musste
zunächst die frage gestellt die kollegin
heike hänsel die linke
ich habe den herrn stabsübergabe über da
kommen ja ladies first danke schön herr
wird zu überleben
herr präsident deutschland ist leider im
bereich der abrüstung obwohl es im
koalitionsvertrag anders stand herr maas
ein totalausfall liegt er mittlerweile
auf platz 7 weltweit was die ausgaben
für militär und rüstung angeht die nato
staaten insgesamt gaben im letzten jahr
eine billion dollar für rüstung aus nun
gibt es einen vorschlag von friedens
forscherinnen der friedens institute im
rahmen des diesjährigen
friedensgutachten es nämlich eine
sogenannte korona friedensdividende
das heißt massiv abzurüsten einzusparen
im bereich der militär- und
rüstungsausgaben um die dringend
benötigten globalen mittel für die
bekämpfung der pandemie und die folgen
der pandemie die sozialen folgen dafür
mittel freizusetzen
wir reden ja hier auch schon über
kürzungen von renten durch erhöhung des
rentenalters und so weiter also es geht
um die soziale frage
um aus der krise herauszugehen
unterstützen sie die idee einer corona
friedensdividende durch massive
abrüstung einsparungen im
rüstungsbereich
deutschland hat bei der pandemie
bekämpfung auch international eine
führende rolle übernommen insbesondere
wenn es darum ging ausreichende finanzen
möglichkeiten zur verfügung zu stellen
wir sind in der internationalen
impfstoff initiative chor wachsen nach
den usa der zweitgrößte geber
wir haben im übrigen auch dank der
entscheidung des bundestages unser
humanitäres engagement ausweiten können
es steht mittlerweile in unserem
haushalt über zwei milliarden euro für
humanitäre hilfe zur verfügung der
bedarf dort ist in der pandemie noch
einmal größer geworden man sieht dass
deutschland zum glück ein land ist das
in der lage ist die herausforderungen
die die pandemie uns gesetzt hat auch
finanziell zu schultern ohne dass wir
unseren verpflichtungen die wir
eingegangen sind innerhalb der nato
dadurch außer kraft setzen müssen
das sehe ich aber völlig anders sie
wissen genau wie haben rückgang an
steuereinnahmen wir haben enorme
verschuldung also insofern ist dieser
aufgeblähte rüstungs haushalt eigentlich
angesichts der sozialen
herausforderungen nicht tragbar
meine frage geht aber auch noch in
richtung atomare abrüstung da hatten sie
sich viel vorgenommen im rahmen des
koalitionsvertrages da hat man nichts
gesehen
nun gibt es eine neue umfrage dass mehr
als 60 prozent der befasst 60 prozent
der bevölkerung die stationierung der us
atomwaffen in deutschland ablehnen
meine frage ist wird die bundesregierung
end
dieser herausforderung gerecht und wird
sie den atomwaffen verbots vertrag nicht
länger blockieren der so eine wichtige
initiative ist im rahmen konkreter
nuklearer abrüstung und er übrigens
nicht im gegensatz steht zum
nichtverbreitungsvertrag was sie ja
gerne sagen herr maas das hat ja ein
gutachten des deutschen bundestages im
januar festgestellt dass sich diese
verträge ergänzen und konkrete schritte
für atomare abrüstung beschreiben werben
sie die us-atomwaffen aus deutschland
abziehen
ich glaube dass das im laufe dieser
legislaturperiode nicht mehr dabei sein
wird
wir haben wir haben eine vielzahl von
abrüstungsinitiativen gestartet wir
haben eine stockholm initiative
gegründet mit 16 anderen ländern wo wir
auf unterschiedliche
abrüstungspolitische themen eingegangen
sind im übrigen nicht nur auf atomare
fragen sondern ein thema das wie ich
finde auch von immer größere bedeutung
wird nämlich was mit neuen technologien
ist autonom waffensystem killer roboter
aber auch die möglichkeiten die die
cyber technik bietet wofür es insgesamt
kein ausreichendes internationales
regelungen gibt grundsätzlich wünschen
wir uns das haben wir unseren
amerikanischen partnern auch gesagt wenn
es zu dem gipfeltreffen zwischen beiden
und putin kommt dass das thema abrüstung
dort auch auf der tagesordnung steht wir
brauchen die usa und russland wenn es um
atomare abrüstung gehen soll
wir haben immer noch kein nachfolger
instrument für den 1 f vertrag die
tatsache dass new start verlängert
worden
das ist aber ein gutes beispiel und
deshalb unterstützen wir alles was
darauf hinausläuft nach in zeiten in
denen und wie ich finde kaum eine
initiative im abrüstungs bereich
international weitergebracht hat in den
letzten jahren
mit einer neuen amerikanischen
administration dieses thema wieder auf
die tagesordnung zu setzen und dafür zu
sorgen dass es effektiv in den kommenden
jahren wieder zur abrüstungspolitik und
auch entscheidungen kommt jetzt die
kollegin kathrin vogler noch eine
nachfrage ja vielen dank herr präsident
herr außenminister sie hatten gerade
über die unterstützung von deutschland
für das programm kovacs gesprochen dass
die ärmsten länder der welt und ist
eigentlich alle länder der welt mit
impfstoffen versorgen soll
nun gibt es ja in vorbereitung auf den g
7 gipfel auch die forderung von unicef
beispielsweise dass die g7 länder die
über große mengen noch nicht zum einsatz
kommen da impfstoffe verfügen und sich
große kapazitäten gesichert haben ein
teil dieser kapazitäten zur verfügung
stellen sollen damit in den ärmsten
ländern der welt die impfprogramme
überhaupt fahrt aufnehmen können das ja
auch durch die probleme lieferprobleme
die durch den ausfall von indien als
großen lieferant entstanden sind
wirklich drängt ist wie stellt sich die
bundesregierung dazu werden sie da mg
siegen auf dem g7-gipfel eine
entsprechende initiative starten
erstmals haben wir erstmals haben wir
uns vorgenommen dass das bisher
avisierte ziel nämlich 20 prozent der
weltbevölkerung über kovacs mit
impfstoff zu versorgen erhöht wird auf
30 prozent was das erst mal notwendig
machen wird dass die initiative mit mehr
geld ausgestattet wird wenn sich aber
alle in dem umfang beteiligen würden wir
das bei deutschland der fall ist während
der schon längst da wir sind aber bereit
auch unsere finanz zuführungen noch
einmal anzupassen
wir werden nach allen zahlen die mir
vorliegen in deutschland ab dem dritten
quartal möglicherweise in die situation
kommen überschüssigen impfstoff zu haben
dann wird darüber zu entscheiden sein
wie man damit umgeht und die haltung der
bundesregierung war immer die dass es
sich um eine globale herausforderung an
und dass wir alle auch in deutschland
erst dann sicher sein werden wenn alle
um uns herum auch sicher sind und
deshalb würde ich das nicht ausschließen
dass überschüssiger impfstoff in der
zeit im dritten und im vierten quartal
dieses jahres von der bundesregierung
auch für andere zur verfügung gestellt
wird
jetzt aber kommt der kollege johannes
schwarz ist bewegung mit der nächsten
frage
herzlichen dank herr präsident ich denke
ich werde trotz der zurückstellung auch
noch pünktlich in den europaausschuss
schaffen gleich sehr geehrter herr
minister ich würde gern nach der
situation der politischen gefangenen in
belarus fragen viele kolleginnen und
kollegen hier im haus haben über fast
alle parteigrenzen hinweg
entweder schon seit vielen jahren über
das programm parlamentarier schützen
parlamentarier oder seit dem letzten
sommer seit dem spätsommer nach den
gefälschten wahlen patenschaften für
politische gefangene in belarus
übernommen auch ich habe für pavel
djokovic der in der europäischen
bewegung belarus engagiert war eine
patenschaft übernommen der seit letztem
herbst in gefangenschaft sitzt und mit
der vom belarussischen regime als
verhaftung betitelten entführung des
oppositionellen bloggers romand roters
hier wird nach der erzwungenen landung
des ryanair flugzeugs in minsk hat sich
die situation auch für alle anderen
politischen gefangenen in belarus ganz
offensichtlich noch mal verschärft in
viele kolleginnen und kollegen hier im
haus in den letzten tagen darüber
informiert worden dass teilweise
langjährige haftstrafen gegenüber diesen
politischen gefangenen für die wir die
patenschaft übernommen haben
verhängt wurden ich möchte gern danach
fragen welche anstrengungen die
bundesregierung aktuell unternimmt um
zur freilassung dieser politisch
gefangenen beizutragen und darauf
gemeinsam mit den europäischen partnern
zu drängen
es war will ich sagen dass sich die
übernahme von patenschaften ausdrücklich
begrüße ich
würde das auch nicht geringschätzen
wollen weil natürlich jeder weiß dass
dadurch unmittelbar nur wenig
auszurichten ist aber es ermöglicht ganz
einfach auch einzelfälle auf der
tagesordnung zu halten und damit auch
das thema insgesamt
wir haben mit unserer botschaft im
rahmen der dialog kanäle die wir noch
haben in linz immer versucht auch bei
einzelfällen auf die dortigen machthaber
einzuwirken es gibt keinen einzigen fall
in dem es ein positives ergebnis gegeben
hat deshalb glaube ich dass insgesamt
die situation politischer gefangener und
die möglichkeit der freilassung ganz
einfach ein thema sein muss dem wir auf
der internationalen bühne mit viel druck
begegnen die sanktions entscheidung die
wir getroffen worden sind sind ganz
sicherlich noch nicht das ende der
fahnenstange
wir werden bereits jetzt innerhalb der
europäischen union weil wir mit weiteren
provokationen rechnen weitere sanktionen
im wirtschaftsbereich im finanzbereich
vorbereiten um deutlich zu machen dass
wir nicht bereit sind nicht nur die
dinge die im zusammenhang mit einem
ryanair-flug geschehen sind zu
akzeptieren sondern auch die situation
politisch gefangener wir selber haben
übrigen für menschen die bedroht sind
ein programm aufgelegt nenne nur die
zahlen der bundespräsident von denen
mittlerweile auch 20 bedrohte gebrauch
gemacht haben die mit ihren familien
nach deutschland gekommen sind die
kurzfristige visa bekommen haben
dies werden wir fortsetzen und
gegebenenfalls auch noch weiter
ausweiten
dann hätte ich gerne eine nachfrage
stellen wir werden das sicherlich auch
als parlamentarier aus dem haus weiter
unterstützen und nicht müde werden
darauf zu drängen auf die freilassung
der politischen gefangenen in belarus
zum glück sind nicht alle menschen die
sich für freiheit demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit in belarus einsetzen
inhaftiert deshalb meine nachfrage es
ist sicherlich schwierig klar eine klare
politische linie gegenüber dem regime zu
fahren und gleichzeitig wege zu finden
wie man die engagierte zivilgesellschaft
unterstützen kann lukaschenko
verschärften momentan die ausreise
beschränkung für die eigenen bürgerinnen
und bürger welle belarus auf dem landweg
verlassen will der braucht eine
permanente aufenthaltsberechtigung in
einem anderen staat sie haben das gerade
schon angesprochen
welche dinge kann die bundesregierung
noch unternehmen um der
zivilgesellschaft die sich für
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit in
belarus einsetzt den rücken zu stärken
die bundesregierung hat schon vor
einiger zeit den aktionsplan
zivilgesellschaft belarus in kraft
gesetzt dort stehen 21 millionen euro
zur verfügung
dort wird versucht freie medien zu
unterstützen aber auch zivil
organisationen die es dort gibt das ist
in der abwicklung außerordentlich
problematisch also die mittel die uns
zur verfügung stehen
dorthin zu bekommen deshalb würden wir
uns wünschen dass von dem programm noch
mehr gebrauch gemacht werden kann
allerdings ist die abwicklung aufgrund
der tatsache dass in belarus die grenzen
nahezu komplett dicht gemacht werden und
nicht nur physisch außerordentlich
schwierig und deshalb versuchen wir mehr
mehr auf einzelfälle zu reagieren
menschen die bedroht sind die heute
bedroht sind aber morgen der gefangenen
sein können
mit erleichterten visabestimmungen wenn
sie das wollen auch in deutschland
aufzunehmen
der kollege sarrazin soll die grünen
oder die nachfrage ich wollte nachfragen
ob sie bei der vorbereitung dieser
sanktionen als bundesregierung sich auch
dafür einsetzen dass die belarussische
kali und erdölindustrie teil einer
möglichen neuen sanktionspaket werden
würde
das ist ein punkt der innerhalb der
europäischen union bereits besprochen
wurde und zu dem wir uns positiv
verhalten haben dann gesehen dann stellt
die nächste frage der kollege ordner von
holz bündnis 90 die grünen
schönen dank herr präsident
herr minister in ihrem eingangsstatement
haben sie die den jetzt gerade heiß
diskutierten versöhnungsprozess mit
namibia nicht angesprochen und möchte
deswegen dazu eine frage stellen im
namibischen parlament hat gestern die
debatte über die gemeinsame erklärung
über den entwurf einer gemeinsamen
erklärung begonnen insofern ist im
prinzip das namibische parlament muss
man mal so sagen uns im bundestag 1
voraus weil wir diese möglichkeiten hier
leider nicht haben
es gibt und widersprüchliche signale es
gibt personen auch im umfeld der
regierungsverhandlungen auf der
libyschen seite die noch probleme mit
dem mit dem abkommen sehen insofern es
gibt auch berichte vom im tagesspiegel
dass der vizepräsident bei dem ja der
chef-unterhändler das büro des
chefunterhändlers drk wie uhr angesetzt
war der erholung wobei der gesagt in
aussicht gestellt hat dass die summe der
der 1,1 milliarden euro in dem entwurf
stehen neu verhandelt werden können
könnten aber ruprecht polenz der
deutsche chef unterhändler meinte dass
das also jetzt unterschriftsreif sei das
sind so ein bisschen widersprüchliche
angaben und da hätte ich ganz gern ihre
einschätzung ist es denn so dass da noch
nachverhandelt werden kann wenn die
summe an geht oder nicht
die beiden verhandlungsdelegationen
haben eine die texaner politischen
erklärung paraphiert zusammen
das ist einfach vor vier wochen in
berlin gewesen das ist die grundlage
dessen was dem namibischen parlament
vorgelegt worden ist die finanzielle
zuwendung belaufen sich auf rund 1,1
milliarden euro
das ist das ergebnis des
verhandlungsprozesses das ist das
ergebnis das ich auch dem deutschen
bundestag mitgeteilt habe das ist auch
das ergebnis
wo wird im deutschen bundestag darum
gebeten haben in der letzten
sitzungswoche die systeme auch noch
einmal aufzurufen
in form einer resolution dies zu
interessieren und auch mitzutragen
genauso wie das im namibischen parlament
jetzt diskutiert wird und insofern gehen
wir davon aus dass es darum geht die
erklärung die paraphiert worden ist auch
abzuschließen ohne noch einmal in die
verhandlungen einzusteigen und deshalb
bin ich guter dinge dass die diskussion
die sie in namibia gibt und niemand ist
niemand hat erwartet dass das eine
diskussion wird in der alle zu 100
prozent zustimmen wenn ich mir aber
anschaue dass insbesondere bei den
finanziellen fragen beträge in den raum
gestellt werden von denjenigen die das
kritisiert haben von mehreren hundert
milliarden euro
die abgeschlossen werden müssten ich
glaube ich dass das nicht ganz der
realität entspricht wir sind der
auffassung dass mit dem text den wir
paraphiert haben eine gute grundlage
gegeben
eine gute grundlage vorliegt um diese
verhandlungen die sich über sechs jahre
hingezogen haben jetzt auch endlich
abzuschließen und wir würden uns sehr
freuen wenn das möglich wäre auch mit
den kolleginnen und kollegen im winter
zügig herr kollege holz von
holznachfrage bitte herr schönen dank
herr präsident
nur dass da kein missverständnis
entsteht ich finde es gut dass es dass
diese verhandlung jetzt zu einem
abschluss gekommen sind und ich würde es
gut dass jetzt etwas vorliegt was man
auch tatsächlich mal diskutieren kann
und was vielleicht auch zu den ersten
zwei wichtigen schritten nämlich die
anerkennung dass das völkermord war und
die bitte um entschuldigung das sind ja
zwei sollen die auch mit geld nichts zu
tun haben dass das endlich jetzt auch
passieren kann nur dass da kein
missverständnis entsteht ich finde es
gut dass wir so weit jetzt gekommen sind
ich habe nur sorge je größer die
akzeptanz in namibia ist klar es wird
immer einzelne geben die das ablehnen
das ist auch mir bewusst aber man müsste
sie ja schon hoffen dass es eine
größtmögliche akzeptanz gibt und wenn
selbst aus den reihen derjenigen die auf
der seite der regierung verhandelt haben
noch vorbehalte bestehen
da wäre es doch sicherlich gut wenn man
die auch noch gewinnen könnte und
deswegen die frage noch mal an sie
wie weit ob sie möglicherweise
konsequenzen daraus ziehen wenn jetzt
der protest anhält oder noch größer wird
und auch aus reihen der
regierungsfraktionen in namibia proteste
kommen das würden wir mit unseren
partnern in der namibischen regierung
besprechen natürlich versucht auch die
dortige regierung eine größtmögliche
gesellschaftliche akzeptanz zu erreichen
ich glaube aber nicht dass das
repräsentativ ist was es an kritik
gegeben hat es ist auch sehr schwer eine
summe zu benennen
die als angemessen betrachtet wird es
wird immer die möglichkeit bestehen zu
sagen na ja es kann auch noch etwas mehr
sein
wir haben uns orientiert an dem was
nötig wäre um eine stiftung langfristig
finanziell auszustatten um projekte in
der landwirtschaft des landkauf es
langfristig auf den weg zu bringen die
etwa 400.000 menschen zugute kommen und
deren wirtschaftlicher situation und
dafür ist ein betrag von 1,1 milliarden
euro über einen bestimmten zeitraum wie
wir finden eine sehr angemessene summe
mit der die projekte die in den
verhandlungsdelegationen besprochen
worden sind alle auch finanziert werden
können und zwar nachhaltig und
langfristig ich habe zwei nachfragen zu
diesem thema einmal die kollegin zumal
die legio der kollege brandner af.de
frau sommer ja vielen dank herr
präsident in dem zusammenhang würde ich
gerne trotzdem wissen wollen bezogen auf
akzeptanz der vertreterinnen und
vertreter vom damaligen deutschen
völkermord betroffenen und zwar auf
welche weise sind diese vertreter also
nachfahren vom damaligen deutschen
völkermord unmittelbar betroffenen
opfergruppen an deutschen ami mission
regierungsverhandlungen beteiligt
gewesen und wie schätzen sie die
aktuelle akzeptanz ausgehandelten
vereinbarungen bei den opfergruppen in
namibia ein
die opfergruppen sind
nahezu alle zugegebenermaßen nicht
komplett alle aber fast alle einbezogen
wurden in die verhandlungen sie sind
teilweise auch mitglied der
verhandlungsdelegation gewesen
es gibt aber auch vertreter der
opfergruppen die den klageweg bevorzugt
haben die deutschland in new york
verklagt haben diese klagen sind alle
abgewiesen worden und sie sind auch in
der instanz in der sie vorlägen jetzt
nicht mehr zugelassen worden so dass wir
eigentlich davon ausgehen dass der
klageweg auch zu keinem ergebnis mehr
führen kann
aber was ist nun einmal so dass es
andere gibt die einen anderen weg ein
anderes verfahren bevorzugt haben weil
sie dachten dass das auf gerichts ebene
entschieden werden kann und damit auch
die finanzfragen gerichtlich geklärt
werden
das ist nicht der fall gewesen es hat
keinen erfolg hat gehabt und deshalb
haben wir mit denjenigen mit denen wir
verhandelt haben der namibische
verhandlungsführer es selbst ein herero
gewesen die maßgeblichen opfergruppen
sind eingebunden gewesen
das was wir zurzeit in der bibel sehen
ist eine debatte darüber die dort
stattfindet die muss auf stattfinden wir
haben auch zu respektieren wenn es dort
kritische stimmen gibt aber wir sind als
bundesregierung nach wie vor der
auffassung dass mit dem auch mit dem
angebot auch den finanziellen zusagen
die wir gemacht haben um verabredete
projekte mittel langfristig nachhaltig
auszustatten
wirklich jetzt einen guten ergebnis
gekommen sind dass wir gerne auch so
abschließen würden dann hat der kollege
brand nach einem nachfolger ja nur mich
um die zuschauer etwas zu erhellen ich
habe es gerade gehört die verhandlungen
werden abgeschlossen ihre einleitenden
worten auch so verstanden
da habe ich gesagt es könnte auch noch
etwas mehr sein nicht ganz so viel wie
gefordert wird also diese knapp 500
milliarden euro
deshalb meine frage sind die
verhandlungen abgeschlossen ja oder nein
und wenn nicht wär verhandelt auf
welcher grundlage nach in welchen
spielraum sehen sie da noch und in dem
zusammenhang nochmal die bemerkung dass
wir als deutschland ja sehr häufig
reparation zu anderen forderungen
ausgesetzt sind sei es der zweite
weltkrieg sei es der erste weltkrieg sei
es jetzt die kolonial vergangen
können sie uns kurz mal schildern welche
anderen länder oder gruppen noch
reparationsforderungen auf welcher
grundlage an deutschland stellen
da ich darauf hingewiesen habe dass der
text einer politischen erklärung
paraphiert worden ist sind die
verhandlungen also auch abgeschlossen
und sie können ja der presse entnehmen
dass es in der vergangenheit immer
wieder länder gegeben hat bei denen über
reparationen diskutiert wurde es geht
etwa für polen aber auch für
griechenland dazu muss man allerdings
sagen dass das mit dem vorliegenden fall
nichts zu tun haben denn dieser
abschluss ist ausschließlich eine auf
freiwilliger basis
es gibt keine rechtsgründe auf der auf
denen diese zahlungen geleistet oder in
aussicht gestellt werden und insofern
ist es auch nicht vergleichbar mit dem
rad reparation szene an sich die nächste
frage stellt der kollege hubert rösel
fdp präsident ist ja gerne außenminister
ich möchte auf die östliche
partnerschaft zu sprechen kommen wir
sind der meinung dass dort eine
neubewertung vorzunehmen wäre
idealerweise unter dem leitgedanken
kooperation statt konfrontation sie
selber waren vor gar nicht langer zeit
noch mit dem äußerungen bezüglich
russland zu vernehmen oder das hat daran
verdienen gehört dass auch die beziehung
zu russland einer überprüfung unterzogen
werden sollten gegebenenfalls eine neue
ausrichtung vorgenommen werden sollte
ich möchte anmerken dass die östliche
partnerschaft natürlich ohne die
berücksichtigung vitale interessen
russland ist sicherlich nicht neu zu
gestalten ist konkrete frage wie ist der
aktuelle stand der standpunkt ihres
hauses in der frage der östlichen
partnerschaft die östliche partnerschaft
ist eines der wesentlichen projekte die
wir zusammen mit anderen vorantreiben es
geht wenn es um neubewertungen geht dort
im wesentlichen um die frage wie wir uns
gegenüber belarus verhalten was russland
angeht
die bundesregierung die auffassung die
eben hier auch bei der debatte
zum 80 jahrestag des angriffs auf die
sowjetunion von nahezu alle wenn ich
mich richtig erinnere vertreten worden
ist dass man das dialogfenster offen
halten muss ich hatte diese woche war
ein telefonat mit seinem russischen
amtskollegen zusammen mit dem
französischen amtskollegen wo wir über
fragen der region aber auch insbesondere
über die ukraine gesprochen haben
also insofern glaube ich dass wir keine
grundsätzliche neubewertung auch für
unsere russland strategie brauchen wir
haben ein interesse an
gutnachbarschaftlichen beziehungen
allerdings haben wir im moment den
eindruck dass in moskau man nicht in der
weise bereit zu sein scheint diesen
dialog mit uns zu führen wie wir uns das
selber wünschen würden nachfrage herr
präsident außenminister der westen zudem
mehr deutschland zweifelsohne zählt hat
den sogenannten arabischen frühling
unterstützt das ergebnis krieg chaos
millionen von flüchtlingen
der westen hat ebenfalls die orangen
revolution in kiew in der ukraine
unterstützt
die ergebnisse sind an sich genauso viel
korruption und misswirtschaft wie vorher
viele politiker aus der politischen welt
sagen dass auch herr selensky mit
sicherheit nicht viel demokratischer ist
als seine seine vorgänger die frage ist
konkret ist die strategie der der
einmischung oder auch mit dem ziel
vielleicht einen regimewechsel regime
change dabei zu führen nicht völlig
kontraproduktiv eigentlich als
gescheitert anzusehen
da wir an derartigen versuchen gar nicht
beteiligt waren kann ich die frage auch
schlecht beantworten wir haben uns
wieder eingemischt in das was arabischen
frühling geschehen ist sondern wir haben
das verfolgt und haben uns dazu auch
verhalten das gilt auch für die
entwicklung in der ukraine
wir unterstützen die ukraine maßgeblich
bei allen reformvorhaben dazu gehört die
von ihnen erwähnte korruption dazu die
bekämpfung der korruption
und vor allen dingen die bekämpfung der
korruption wird es eines der
reformvorhaben die ist in der
ukrainischen regierung gibt der
ukrainische präsident hat bei seiner
zwar vor allen dingen zwei themen
benannt dem wichtigste das eine ist
korruptionsbekämpfung das andere ist der
frieden im dom bass und bei beiden
punkten würde ich mal sagen ist man noch
nicht am ende des weges aber man kann
sich der deutschen unterstützung auch in
zukunft sicher sein
demnächst die frage gestellt die
kollegin marie fragt sich über meinen
fdp herr präsident
herr minister nach 20 jahren einsatz in
afghanistan verlassen nun die truppen
dieses land und in diesen jahren hatten
wir viel unterstützung von heimischer
bevölkerung die sogenannten afghanischen
ortskräfte als kulturvermittler als
dolmetscher und auch als dienstleister
gerade die kulturvermittler und
dolmetscher haben an die demokratie
geglaubt an die freiheit ihres landes an
die zukunft ihres landes
und sie haben uns unterstützt auch unter
lebensgefahr unter hohem risiko und
haben auch großes vertrauen in uns
ziehen wir aus afghanistan ab dass es
keine überraschung aber die
geschwindigkeit ist dann doch eine
überraschung meine frage an sie ist
letzte woche wurde entschieden dass die
kulturvermittler die zwei jahre länger
also die in den letzten zwei jahren oder
darüber hinaus die bundeswehr
unterstützt haben nicht die möglichkeit
haben nach deutschland auszuweichen um
der rache der taliban zu entgehen
vielleicht können sie uns erklären warum
nach zwei jahren die gefahr geringer ist
als die die jetzt unmittelbar davor sind
nach deutschland kommen zu können
frank zimmermann frau abgeordnete will
zunächst einmal sagen dass wir uns der
bedeutung der entscheidung die wir dort
treffen bewusst sind sowohl das
verteidigungsministerium das auswärtige
amt aber auch das innenministerium und
auch das bmz dass er für viele mit
vermittler verantwortlich ist sind dazu
in einem sehr intensiven dialog wir
haben auch heute morgen noch einmal
darüber
brauchen wir gehen davon aus dass der
der der personenkreis umgehend es bisher
geht sich auf etwa 2.000 menschen
beläuft wir sind dabei auch bereit
gewesen auch weiter in die vergangenheit
zurück zu gehen teilweise bis in das
jahr 2013
wir haben innerhalb des auswärtigen
amtes das visaverfahren so gestaltet
dass davon auszugehen ist dass bis zu
dem zeitpunkt an dem die bundeswehr und
anderer streitkräfte afghanistan
verlassen haben alle anträge abgewickelt
sind das heißt bis zum vierten juli wir
sprechen zurzeit noch einmal darüber ob
es die möglichkeit gibt im übrigen auch
innerhalb dieses zeitraumes menschen
darüber hinaus die möglichkeit zu geben
zu uns zu kommen
das müssen wir jetzt sehr zügig tun weil
der vierte juli wurden aufhaltsame näher
kommt das ist noch nicht komplett
entschieden ich würde nicht ausschließen
dass es noch einige personen zusätzlich
geben wird die die möglichkeit bekommen
eine auf teils genehmigung in
deutschland zu erzielen
das ist da ja wirklich um lebensgefahr
geht dass diese menschen gefahr laufen
an den taliban ermordet zu werden
inwieweit die bundesregierung bereit ist
finanziell unter zu unterstützen das
eben sehr schnell auch nach deutschland
ausgabe reist werden kann gibt es da
eine regelung dahingehend dass man
gegebenenfalls in vorleistung tritt
haben sie sich damit beschäftigt und
noch eine weitere frage ist es ja jetzt
eine frage auch wo alle zu uns schauen
denn wir werden ja sind in anderen
krisengebieten wir werden immer wieder
unterstützung der dortigen menschen
brauchen und was das für uns bedeutet
wenn die bundeswehr
eben diese hilfe braucht aber am ende
das image entstehen könnte ja die
bundeswehr braucht aber wenn es zum
schwur kommt dann sind die deutschen weg
eben deshalb haben wir ein eigenes und
zwar ein vitales interesse daran
für zukünftige einsätze mit den menschen
die für uns gearbeitet haben
verantwortungsvoll umzugehen
es wird auch nicht am geld scheitern die
menschen rechtzeitig aus afghanistan
raus zu bekommen will nur mal ein
beispiel nennen es ist auch darüber
gesprochen wurde wurden sonderflüge zu
organisieren allerdings hat man davon
abstand genommen weil das ganz einfach
auch ein schwieriges bild gebe auch in
afghanistan dass menschen in afghanistan
jetzt noch unabhängig von der begründung
die nachvollziehbar ist sozusagen
flugzeug weise das land verlassen auf
der flucht sind und deshalb hat uns die
afghanische regierung auch immer sehr
deutlich gesagt dass sie das unterstützt
aber dass wir bitte darauf achten sollen
dass kein bild entsteht das darauf
hinausläuft dass jetzt die große flucht
aus afghanistan aus kabul beginnt auch
viele mittlere organisationen haben wie
weiter dort vor ort sind die wir auch
vor ort brauchen werden haben uns darum
gebeten mit dem thema so umzugehen dass
es in afghanistan nicht eine diskussion
gibt und einen run darauf dass möglichst
alle jetzt das land verlassen können
insbesondere die kräfte die dort auch
gebraucht werden in den mittleren
organisationen und deshalb haben wir uns
darauf beschränkt dass diejenigen die
unmittelbar für die bundeswehr
gearbeitet haben von den angeboten die
wir machen auch gebrauch machen können
ich will nur sagen auch wenn das aus
hiesiger sicht vielleicht schwieriger
ist nachzuvollziehen die bilder die in
afghanistan ersteht entstehen dass immer
mehr menschen das land verlassen ist
etwas was auch zu einer vertrauenskrise
in diesem land führen kann und deshalb
versuchen wir den menschen die wirklich
eine gefährdung haben die nachgeprüft
ist die bewiesen ist die möglichkeit
nach deutschland zu kommen
auch schnellstmöglich zu gewährleisten
zu einer nachfrage die kollegin vielen
dank herr außenminister
das lässt ja sozusagen tief oder blicken
überhaupt was den umgang der
bundesregierung mit dem land afghanistan
angeht deshalb möchte ich eine frage
dazu zu stellen die im weitesten sinne
auch damit berührt ist und zwar fand ja
gestern wieder eine sammel abschiebung
nach afghanistan statt wir wissen um die
sicherheitslage
wir wissen
dass die vielzahl der anschläge gerade
auch auf zivile zunimmt
wir wissen dass die dritte welle der
korona pandemie große schwierigkeiten
verursacht vor ort das gesundheitssystem
aufrecht zu erhalten und deshalb möchte
ich sie fragen wie sie unter all diesen
umständen die fortführung der sammel
abschiebung ja auch mit logistischer
unterstützung des auswärtigen amtes
weiter ja mit ihrem gewissen vereinbaren
können und verbunden mit der frage ob
sie sich für einen abschiebestopp
einsetzen werden nach afghanistan ich
glaube die lage vor ort lässt diese
überlegung zu und ob es einen weiteren
lagebericht des auswärtigen amtes zur
lage in afghanistan geben wird wird es
sicherlich irgendwann geben zu ihrer
einleitenden bemerken würde ja bände
sprechen wie wir mit afghanistan umgehen
würde ich mein besuch in afghanistan
empfehlen und mit den verantwortlichen
dort zu sprechen und darüber und eben
mal die frage zu stellen wie sie in
afghanistan innerhalb der afghanischen
regierung aber auch fehler
zivilgesellschaftlichen organisationen
das deutsche engagement über die letzten
jahre dort empfinden
ich kann das mit meinem gewissen
vereinbaren von denen 42 menschen die
zurückgeführt worden sind sind vier sind
40 straftäter die in deutschland
straftaten begangen haben teilweise
schwere straße schwere schwerste
straftaten und insofern glaube ich nicht
dass uns eine abschiebung stock dort
weiterhilft wir haben die lage in
afghanistan in den lageberichten
beschrieben wir werden ganz
selbstverständlich insbesondere nach dem
abzug der internationalen truppen den
lagebericht fortschreiben und anpassen
an das ressort dann geschehen wird in
der hoffnung dass das was viele
prognostizieren dass das chaos ausbricht
eben aus ausbleibt das ist eher ein
grund weshalb die afghanischen
streitkräfte von der nato und von
unseren verbündeten in den letzten
jahren dort ausgebildet worden sind
ursprünglich in frage zurückkehren
wir haben bedingt gehört wie die
soldaten beziehungsweise die hilfskräfte
unserer deutschen soldaten behandelt
werden aber im grunde gilt es ja im
grunde für die entwicklungs kräfte auch
wir haben ja dort leute die in projekten
arbeiten die gerade der dorn im auge der
taliban sind zum beispiel
frauenförderung und so weiter die aktive
mit einer demokratie förderung die
diametral projekte betrieben haben die
jetzt auf nicht wohlgefallen der taliban
fahren würden halten sie es für richtig
dass es nur eine privilegierte ausreise
möglichkeit geschaffen wird für soll
dafür kräfte die den verteidigungs
kräften geholfen haben oder eben auch
muss es so was eigentlich auch für die
entwicklungshelfer geben
ich will mal sagen all diese fragen
haben ja die grundlage dass in wenigen
wochen die taliban in afghanistan
das zepter in der hand haben das ist
nicht die grundlage meiner annahme
wir gehen aber davon aus und insofern
ist es sicherlich richtig dass die
kampfhandlungen erst einmal zunehmen
werden aber gleichzeitig gibt es einen
friedensprozess zwischen den taliban und
der afghanischen regierung der ja nicht
ausgesetzt worden ist und den ich auch
nicht für unerreichbar heute und wenn
sie so sehr ich das unterstütze alle die
für die bundeswehr gearbeitet haben die
einer unmittelbaren gefährdungslage
unterliegen jetzt das angebot bekommen
nach deutschland zu kommen
das auszuweiten auf die
entwicklungshilfeorganisation bedeutet
dann reden wir nicht mehr über 2000
menschen dann reden wir über 20.000
menschen
das sieht aus wie ein massenexodus aus
afghanistan
was gibt das für ein bild in der
afghanischen bevölkerung wie sollen wir
die über 400 millionen euro an ziviler
hilfe die wir jedes jahr für afghanistan
zur verfügung stellen
überhaupt noch dorthin bekommen wenn die
organisation dort über kein personal
mehr verfügen also ich bin wir reden
darüber wirklich jeden bei dem die
gefährdungslage offensichtlich ist und
anerkannt wird ein angebot zu machen
nach deutschland zu kommen
ich kann auch verstehen dass es
emotional total nachvollziehbar ist das
soweit auszuweiten wie es nur geht
aber bitte denken sie auch an die bilder
die in afghanistan entstehen und die
vertrauenskrise in
einem ohnehin geschüttelten land wenn
immer mehr menschen das land verlassen
und deshalb bin ich dafür das angebot
das wir gemacht haben in dem rahmen zu
beschränken zunächst einmal auf die
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter
insbesondere der bundeswehr es
auszuweiten auf alle organisationen auf
alle zivilgesellschaftlichen
organisationen ich kann ihnen auch nicht
sagen ob immer unmittelbar eine
gefahrenlage vorliegt ich könnte mir
sogar vorstellen dass wenn die taliban
in afghanistan die macht übernommen
haben dass sie sehr wohl ein interesse
daran haben dass zivilgesellschaftliche
organisation weiter funktionieren wie
das internationale geld verteilen also
entschuldigen sie ich will nur darauf
hinweisen dass es auch eine andere
sichtweise gibt die konsequenzen in
afghanistan hat die ich nicht für
positiv weiter bevor ich die kollegin
vogeler das wort zu einer letzten
nachfrage zu dieser frage gebe weiß ich
darauf hin dass wir noch zehn minuten
fragezeit haben ich bitte also bei
fragen wie auch bei den antworten das
optische signal auch zu beachten und
wenn es auf rot springt ist auch die
antwortzeit beendet bitte kollegin vogel
vielen dank frau präsidentin der
minister an dieser stelle möchte ich
noch mal auch noch mal nachfragen wie
die bundesregierung genau gegenteiliger
aussagen auch bewertet also der
ehemalige bundeswehroffizier und leiter
der ngo kinderhilfe afghanistan hat
nämlich als bekannt wurde dass der abzug
der militärs jetzt schneller
vonstattengehen soll sehr sehr deutlich
im deutschlandfunk gesagt dass das für
ihn und seine lokalen mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter bedeutet dass sie in das
sie künftig sicherer sein werden dass
sie ihrer ihrer hilfsarbeiten den aufbau
von schulen in größerer sicherheit
vollziehen können weil sie eben nicht
unter den verdacht geraten teil oder
nahestehend einer kriegspartei zu sein
ist das nicht auch ein aspekt den man
berücksichtigen muss das ist zumindest
eine stimme die es auch gibt es ist
außerordentlich schwer zu
prognostizieren wie sich die lage in
afghanistan weiter entwickeln wird wenn
die ausländischen streitkräfte das land
verlassen haben ich habe eben schon mal
darauf hingewiesen dass wir die hoffnung
haben und nicht nur die hoffnung sondern
diesen prozess unterstützen dass die
innerafghanische friedensverhandlungen
fortgesetzt werden und wenn das dazu
führt dass bei einzelnen organisationen
auf der seite der taliban nicht mehr der
verdacht gehegt wird dass sie fremden
mächten zu arbeiten und das zu mehr
sicherheit für die mitarbeiterin der
mitarbeiter führt dann ist das
sicherlich gut so ganz verlassen darauf
kann man sich sicherlich aber auch nicht
die nächste frage stellt die kollegin
helin in flims um ja ich will noch mal
dass die machen namibia aufrufen die
vereinbarung und noch einmal mit meiner
differenzierten frage müssen wollen nach
welchen kriterien wurde der zusätzliche
unterstützungsbeitrag von 1,1 milliarden
euro ermittelt den namibier verteilt auf
30 jahre für wiederaufbau versöhnung von
deutschland erhalten soll
wieso 30 jahre vielleicht können sie das
auch noch mal erläutern und inwieweit
wurde hier
auch geprüft welche materiellen schäden
durch die deutsche kolonialherrschaft
und den völkermord schätzungsweise
insgesamt entstanden ist
das ist nicht gegenstand der verhandlung
gewesen dass es gegenstand der
gerichtsverfahren in new york gewesen
wir haben mit der namibischen seite mit
der namibischen verhandlungsdelegation
über projekte besprochen um die
landbevölkerung der herero und nama die
marginalisiert sind in namibia
wirtschaftliche hilfen zukommen zu
lassen
das ist im bereich bildung der fall das
ist im bereich der landwirtschaft weil
das ein sehr landwirtschaftlich
exponierter bereich ist und das land
kaufes der fall gewesen bei diesen
projekten ging es uns darum sie
langfristig zu finanzieren also auf
einen zeitraum von 30 jahren
und um diese projekte auch über diesen
zeitraum operationalisieren zu können
sind wir auf diesen betrag von 1,1
milliarden euro gekommen
und nicht nur wir sondern auch zusammen
in den verhandlungsdelegationen und ich
selber habe drei telefonate mit der
namibischen kolleginnen dazu geführt und
das ist das ergebnis das jetzt vorliegt
und bei dem wir alles daran setzen
werden das ist auch gegenstand einer
gemeinsam unterzeichneten politischen
erklärung wird sie haben das funktion
nachfrage ja sie haben ja auch als sie
die vereinbarung auf der pressekonferenz
vor einer woche öffentlich gemacht haben
gesagt dass diese vereinbarung bedeutet
ja kein schlussstrich was ich sehr
richtig finde und wichtig in dem
zusammenhang würde ich trotzdem auch
fragen wollen
wie sieht denn die gedenk politik der
also deutsche gedenkt politik dann aus
wie wird
dies als in sie gedenkt politik
eingebettet in deutschland es wird eine
gemeinsame stiftung geben die auch aus
diesen mitteln finanziert werden soll
und langfristig unterhalten soll diese
stiftung soll die gedenkarbeit
bearbeiten das heißt mit ausstellung mit
austausch jugendaustausch mit den
unterschiedlichsten möglichkeiten die
ist heute in der erinnerungsarbeit gibt
sicherlich auch mit publikationen die
sowohl in namibia als auch in
deutschland vertrieben werden sollen und
der nucleus dieser gedenke und
erinnerungsarbeit soll die stiftung
werden die auch aus diesen mitteln
finanziert wird zu einer weiteren
nachfrage der kollege von holz das wird
schon eine frau präsidentin herr
minister sie sagten vorhin dass die
projekte sich darauf beziehen die
landbevölkerung der affäre wurden aber
zu unterstützen wenn man jetzt den
entwurf dieses dieser dieser erklärung
gemeinsamen erklärung guckt sind daher
sieben regionen also regions genannt
unter anderem auch die region khomas die
ja unter anderem die hauptstadt windhuk
beinhaltet wäre die frage wie wird denn
sichergestellt weil in dieser region
leben sehr sehr viele menschen die ihm
keine und nama sind gerade auch in der
stadt windhoek wie werden wird denn
sichergestellt dass am ende auch
tatsächlich die nachfahren oder der
angehörigen der opfer gruppen im den
unmittelbaren und sag ich mal spürbaren
genuss der projekte kommen auch wenn das
sich eben offensichtlich auf regionen
erstreckt die eben nicht
schwerpunktmäßig von uwe und nama
bewohnt sind also die regionen die
festgelegt worden sind sind natürlich
auch auf besonderen wunsch der libyschen
seite festgelegt worden
aufgrund der notwendigkeiten die man
dort gesehen hat dass die mittel dort
auch zielgerichtet
ankommen das wird jetzt arbeit in der
umsetzung in der praktischen umsetzung
sein
zusammen mit der namibischen seite wir
glauben dass wir auch mit organisationen
wie der witz dabei durchaus behilflich
sein können also einzelne projekte auch
mit organisieren oder mit deutschen
organisationen operationalisieren und
damit natürlich auch die möglichkeit
haben steuern und eingreifen zu können
zusammen mit der namibischen seite aber
das sind tatsächlich fragen die jetzt
auf uns zukommen werden
ehrlich gesagt im moment wäre ich schon
ausreichend glücklich wenn es uns
gelingt das thema einmal grundsätzlich
abzuschließen mit der erklärung mit der
bitte um vergebung mit der akzeptanz der
summe und mit den vereinbarten projekten
die uns dann sehr sehr lange
beschäftigen werden aber auch die
grundlage dafür sind dass das durch
dieses thema immer belastete verhältnis
zwischen deutschland und namibia endlich
mal sich öffnen wird
die nächste frage gestellt der kollege
ihr weg bundesminister erlauben sie mir
auch zu dem themenkomplex noch mal eine
frage zu stellen und zwar wie soll denn
wirklich jetzt die vollendung passieren
weil wir hatten gerade das in namibia
gerade im parlament dort diskutiert
debattiert wird
wann wird das eigentlich im deutschen
bundestag debattiert wird das parlament
überhaupt mit eingeschlossen wird das
parlament das sozusagen ratifizieren
oder wie ist da die planung der
deutschen bundesregierung also erst mal
haben wir in den letzten wochen versucht
auch die top leute einzubeziehen in den
fortgang dieser verhandlung die sind
alle immer sehr vertraulich gewesen
deshalb ist das für uns ein bisschen
schwierig gewesen weil uns die namibia
gebeten haben nicht über summen
öffentlich in deutschland zu sprechen
weil das die diskussion in namibia
erschwert hätte so und unser vorschlag
wäre natürlich dass der bundestag sich
damit befasst das ist jetzt kein
vertragswerk das der ratifizierung durch
das parlament bedürfte das ist auch in
namibia nicht so aber natürlich wollen
wir das könnte man zb eine resolution
des bundestages eine entscheidung
treffen dass man so dass man das was man
dort abgeschlossen hat zusammen mit der
namibischen regierung unterstützt
ratifiziert werden im formellen silber
muss es nicht aber ich glaube es gibt
auch die erwartungshaltung in namibia
genauso wie das namibische parlament
sich damit auseinandersetzen dass auch
das deutsche parlament sich damit
auseinandersetzt und im besten fall auch
eine unterstützende entscheidung dazu
trifft die wohl letzte frage in dieser
befragung stellt der kollege jürgen
trittin herr minister
ich möchte gern noch mal auf den anfang
ihrer ausführungen auf das treffen zu
den g7 zurückkommen gestern hat die
bundeskanzlerin beim 20 jahresfeier des
nachhaltigkeitsrats einen
bemerkenswerten satz gesagt
zum thema klimaschutz was wir bisher
gemacht haben war schlicht zu wenig wenn
das jetzt im mittelpunkt des g7 treffens
steht freilich sie was wollen sie dort
anbieten
zusätzlich zu dem was ihre eigene
regierungschefin als zu wenig bezeichnet
sind ja verschiedene dinge denkbar
sie könnten sich überlegen dem aufruf
der internationalen energieagentur zu
folgen und im rahmen von regeln für
green finance keinerlei investitionen
mehr in fossile infrastruktur zuzulassen
in solchen regeln sie könnten gemeinsam
mit den usa john carey hat das
verschiedenen nicht vorgeschlagen sagen
wenn wir unsere industrie co2 frei
gestalten
da muss die vor dumping konkurrenz
geschützt werden deswegen lass uns doch
auch so etwas wie ein cross border
adjustment verständigen was sind ihre
vorschläge für die g7 um das zu
überwinden was die kanzlerin gesagt hat
es war zu wenig also letzteren was der
dumping wettbewerb angeht schließe ich
mich schon mal an das ist auch die
haltung die wir vertreten auch innerhalb
der europäischen union in der diskussion
die es dazu gibt es auch ein thema
gewesen dass ich mit john kerry
besprochen habe als er vor zwei wochen
hier gewesen ist
er hat da auch noch ein paar eigene
gedanken dazu also da müssen wir die
amerikanischen partner auch noch mit von
überzeugen wir wollen die
transatlantische klima brücke wieder
aufsetzen
ansonsten ist es mir leider nicht
möglich gewesen die komplette rede der
bundeskanzlerin zu diesem thema zu lesen
aber ich bin mir sicher dass sie auch
vorschläge gemacht hat die auf dem
g7-gipfel dann auch thematisiert werden
darf ich noch
noch mal nachfragen sie dürfen nach
fragen bleiben aber dieses mal mit in
der zeit ja bundesminister ich würde
noch mal gern konkret nachfragen
innerhalb der europäischen union gibt es
ja streit darüber ob ich hab es
akustisch nicht verstanden hat der
europäischen union gibt es ja einen
auffassungsunterschiede darüber ob auch
künftig fossile infrastruktur aus
mitteln der europäischen union
finanziert werden sollen
die er die internationale energieagentur
bekanntermaßen keine grüne veranstaltung
plädiert dafür das zu beenden
plädieren sie jetzt dafür dass wir auch
aussteigen aus der finanzierung zum
beispiel von gas infrastrukturen etwa im
südlichen gas corridor aus der
finanzierung von neuen
flüssiggasterminals und ähnlich danke
herr minister ich beende die befragung